[Music]
the world we live in feels normal
ordinary it feels like this is just how
humans exist and always existed
but it's not
never before have we humans lived in a
world as sophisticated and engineered to
our needs as today giving us the luxury
to forget about ourselves and not worry
about survival
food shelter security all of this is
more or less taken for granted
but we're a special few for more than
99.99
of human history life was completely
different and there's no such thing as
just one human history
[Music]
our story begins six million years ago
when the tribe of homeonini split and
our relationship with the apes ended
2.8 million years ago the genus of homo
the first humans emerged
we like to think of ourselves as the
only humans but this is far from the
truth
when we homo sapiens sapiens came into
existence two hundred thousand years ago
there were at least six other human
species around
cousins of comparable intelligence and
ability which must have been incredibly
scary kind of like
living with aliens
some of them were very successful
homo erectus for example survived for 2
million years
10 times longer than modern humans have
existed
the last of the other humans disappeared
around 10 000 years ago
we don't know what caused them to die
out
modern humans have at least a few
percent of neanderthal and other human
dna so there was some mixing but
certainly not enough to be a merger
between species
so we don't know if our cousins went
away because they lost the battle over
resources or because of a series of
minor genocides either way only we
remain
back to the beginnings of humanity
2.8 million years ago early humans used
tools but did not make a lot of progress
for nearly two million years
until they learned to control fire
fire meant cooking which made food more
nutritious which contributed to the
development of our brain
it also produced light and warmth which
made days longer and winters less
gruesome
on top of that it not only scared
predators away it could also be used for
hunting a torched wood or grassland
provided small animals nuts and tubers
that were pre-roasted
from 300 000 years ago most of the
different human species lived in small
hunter-gatherer societies
they had fire wood and stone tools
planned for the future buried their dead
and had cultures of their own but most
importantly they spoke to each other
probably in a kind of proto-language
less complex than ours
if we had a time machine how far would
we be able to go back steal a few babies
and raise them today without anyone
noticing that they're a bit different
there is much debate
anatomically modern humans emerged 200
000 years ago but probably 70 000 years
is as far as we could travel back and
still snatch a behaviorally modern human
before that the babies would probably
lack a few crucial gene mutations
necessary to build a brain with modern
language and abstract thinking abilities
at some point around fifty thousand
years ago there was an explosion in
innovation tools and weapons became more
sophisticated and culture became more
complex because at this point humans had
a multi-purpose brain and a more
advanced language to communicate
information with each other effectively
and down to the last detail
this allowed much closer cooperation and
is what really makes us different from
any other creature on earth
not our comparatively weak bodies and
inferior senses but the ability to
cooperate flexibly in large groups
unlike for example rigid beehives or
intimate but tiny wolf packs
as our brain evolved we became able to
do something life had been unable to do
up to this point
one expand knowledge quickly
two preserve the knowledge gained over
generations
three
build on past knowledge to gain even
deeper insights
this seems daft but until then
information had to be passed on from
generation to generation mostly through
genetics which is not efficient
still for the next 40 000 years human
life remained more or less the same
there was little to build upon our
ancestors were only one animal among
many
building a skyscraper without knowing
what a house is is hard
but while it's easy to be arrogant in
our attitude to our ancestors this would
be ignorant humans 50 000 years ago were
survival specialists they had a detailed
mental map of their territory their
senses were fine-tuned to the
environment they knew and memorized a
great amount of information about plants
and animals
they could make complicated tools that
required years of careful training and
very fine motor skills
their bodies compared to our athletes
today just because of their daily
routines and they lived a rich social
life within their tribe
survival required so many skills that
the average brain volume of early modern
humans might even have been bigger than
it is today
as a group we know more today but as
individuals our ancestors were superior
to us
but then around 12 000 years ago in
multiple locations humans developed
agriculture
everything changed very quickly before
survival as a hunter and forager
required superb physical and mental
abilities in all fields from everybody
with the rise of the agricultural age
individuals could increasingly rely on
the skills of others for survival
this meant that some of them could
specialize maybe they worked on better
tools
maybe they took time to breed more
resistant crops or better livestock
maybe they started inventing things
as farming got more and more efficient
what we call civilization began
agriculture gave us a reliable and
predictable food source which allowed
humans to hoard food on a large scale
for the first time which is much easier
to do with grains than meat
a food stock required protection which
led to communities living together in
tighter spaces
first early defense structures were
built the need for organization grew
the more organized we got the faster
things became efficient villages became
cities cities became kingdoms kingdoms
became empires
connections between humans exploded
which led to opportunities to exchange
knowledge progress became exponential
about 500 years ago the scientific
revolution began mathematics physics
astronomy biology and chemistry
transformed everything we thought we
knew
the industrial revolution followed soon
after laying the foundation for the
modern world
as our overall efficiency grew
exponentially more people could spend
their lifetime contributing to the
progress of humanity
revolutions kept happening the invention
of the computer its evolution into a
medium we all use on a daily basis and
the rise of the internet shaped our
world it's hard to grasp how fast all of
that happened it's been about 125 000
generations since the emergence of the
first human species
about 7 500 generations since the
physiologically modern human saw the
light of day
500 generations ago what we call
civilization began
20 generations ago we learned how to do
science and the internet became
available to most people only one
generation ago today we live in the most
prosperous age humanity has ever
experienced we have transformed this
planet from the composition of its
atmosphere to large scale changes in its
landscape and also in terms of the other
animals in existence
we light up the night with artificial
stars and put people in a metal box in
the sky some have even walked on our
moon we put robots on other planets
we've looked deep into the past of the
universe with mechanical eyes our
knowledge and our way of acquiring and
storing more of it has exploded the
average high school student today knows
more about the universe than a scholar a
few centuries ago
humans dominate this planet even if our
rule is very fragile
we are still not that different from our
ancestors 70 000 years ago but your
lifestyle has existed for less than
0.001 percent of human history
from here on there's no saying what the
future holds for us
we're building a skyscraper but we're
not sure if it's standing on a solid
foundation or if we're building it on
quicksand
let's leave it with that for now the
next time you miss your train your
burger is not hot enough or someone cuts
in line remember how special this made
up human world is maybe it's not worth
being upset about all those little
things
okay this was our first take on making a
history related video we'd love to make
much more of them but they take even
more time than our average video so we
might do three or four a year your
feedback's very welcome here thank you
so much for watching and if you want to
support us directly you can do so on
patreon it really helps us out
while you think about it here are more
videos if you need more distraction